passage à tabac john lurie agression
d'une jeune fille à béziers
affrontements dans le quartier des
grésillés mais aussi le décès récent de
deux adolescents dans le département de
l'essonne certains territoires ont été
le théâtre d'affrontements violents
ces récents événements ont à nouveau
braqués les projecteurs sur le phénomène
des rixes entre bandes rivales est
désormais le rôle des réseaux sociaux
est largement pointés du doigt ça avait
plutôt tendance à baisser mais nous
voyons que les terribles faits
d'actualité nous rappelle que c'est
toujours très présent du fait notamment
du mimétisme des réseaux sociaux alors à
quel point les réseaux sociaux attise la
haine entre bandes rivales la réponse
dans facture les règlements de compte
entre gangs sont loin d'être un
phénomène nouveau il ya des dizaines
d'années et l'arrivée massive du trafic
de stupéfiants et la diffusion des armes
à feu honte à graver ce phénomène est
aujourd'hui un tout autre élément
entrant qui est nouveau c'est que ça se
voit c'est que ça soit à cause des
réseaux sociaux c'est ce qu'elle
s'assoit à cause de la télévision de ces
affrontements sont traditionnelles mais
jamais ils n'ont été aussi proches en
termes de la proximité de l'image et
c'est l'image qui créent des mots chaud
et surtout l'image de la mortalité snap
chatte instagram twitter tik tok mais
aussi télégramme ces plateformes sont
désormais largement utilisé par les
banques dans un cycle en trois temps
avant l'altercation pendant puis après
avant le conflit
les plateformes permettent aux bandes de
fixer un lieu de rendez-vous ou
contribuent parfois à faire émerger une
altercation qui s'explique simplement on
sait qu'une partie de la vie des
adolescents aujourd'hui se passer une
vie qui est digital et sociale qui est
numérique
donc il est normal que ce qui se passait
dans le portrait en ciel se passe dans
distant ciel et qu'il ya un transfert de
compliquer tu as lité parce qu'on passe
beaucoup plus de temps sur dans l'espace
ni la distance induite par l'outil
numérique facilite peut-être les mises
au défi forme de dénigrement et la
naissance de deux contentieux d'une
centrifugeuse 1
ou la haine se développe de manière
assez assez puissante avec le
développement des messagerie crypté
alors on peut penser notamment un
télégramme permettent aux belligérants
de ceux de se donner rendez vous à
l'abri des oreilles indiscrètes ans je
dirais pour lancer les défis pour
provoquer les lits l'amplification du
phénomène il son organisation par les
messages décrypter qui font que on est
maintenant à des bagarres qui sont
facilitées on a pu à se déplacer en
métro pour s'échauffer les esprits
simples de simples échanges par
messagerie sur les réseaux permet tout
d'un coup de cristalliser la la colère
et de provoquer les conditions d'une
d'une bagarre
au cours de ces affrontements entre
bandes ont fait face à un phénomène de
plus en plus récurrents la
digitalisation découvre concrètement les
affrontements sont diffusés sur les
réseaux sociaux que ce soit en temps
réel ou à l'issue de l'altercation
la mise en ligne de ces vidéos à
plusieurs objectifs comme ridiculiser à
l'adversaire en montrant sa domination
mais aussi perpétuer un cycle de
violences ces bagarres sont d'autant
plus virulentes et ont des effets
d'autant plus dévastateur que quand
elles sont filmées elles sont filmées à
foix en direct c'est comme les jeux du
cirque moderne 1 il peut avoir des
centaines voire des milliers
d'internautes qui m'ont ben va suivre ça
comme un comme un comme un match peut
même assister à une scénarisation delà
de la bagarre est sûr qu'il ya un effet
amplificateur donc à partir du moment la
vidéo circule avec elle constitue une
preuve à la fois de l'humiliation d'un
côté et de la domination de l'autre
elle appelle des réponses et elles
alimentent cette dynamique de vindicatif
de vengeance des très compliqué pour un
adolescent qui a justement juste dont
l'honneur et le principal capital social
ne pas chercher à être à se réhabiliter
sauf que dans les logiques de banc dans
le bain dès dans les logiques de rue la
réhabilitation elle va passer par usage
de la force physique
essentiellement on vient de le voir les
réseaux sociaux créés et entretiennent
les tensions entre les bandes mais
l'objet des conflits lui n'a pas
vraiment évolué avec l'émergence de ces
plateformes
l'enjeu central avec ces rivalités c'est
un enjeu de réputation il n'y a pas de
guerre matériel n'y a pas de
revendications politiques
c'est pas non plus une guerre de classes
ceux qui se battent se ressent l'enjeu
il est honorifique
c'est un enjeu de réputation ce qui est
important c'est que les réputations sont
numériques auront à partir du moment où
les informations circuit les messages
circulent ils sont commentés et tous ces
commentaires alimentent et si un effet
d'amplification et ceux ci se trouvent
là c'est à dire que aujourd'hui tout un
chacun dans sa chambre peut commenter
alimenter ses enjeux de réputation et
celle ces rivalités là les ressorts des
affrontements finalement assez peu
évolué c'est peut-être la seule chose
qui reste c'est très humain en aidant
l'accaparation d'un territoire donc ça
ç'a toujours été le cas
des histoires de
de coeur on est souvent sur des sur des
prétextes très fallacieux un mot de
travers sur internet une vidéo qui
tourne en ridicule un quartier adverse
un commentaire après un match de foot
amateur on est vraiment sur des choses
extrêmement basique extrêmement futile
mais qui ont des répercussions énormes
on est sur quelque chose qui est une
énorme distorsion entre le resort delà
de la bataille et il ses conséquences
qui vont jusqu'à la mort comme on l'a vu
dans l'essonne des affrontements
violents qui sont d'ailleurs déflorée
par les autorités puisque malgré les
deux confinement liés à l'épidémie de
kovy 19
les chiffres du ministère de l'intérieur
font état de 350 cet affrontement entre
bandes rivales en 2020 sur tout le
territoire national contre 288 en 2010
non et encore c'est une fourchette basse
puisque tous les affrontements entre
bandes rivales ne conduisent pas
nécessairement un dépôt de plainte ou à
des interventions des forces de l'ordre
et ne se doute pas tous recensés dans
les chiffres officiels
si le lien entre l'augmentation des
affrontements et les réseaux sociaux
n'est pas clairement établi la médiation
et la prévention sont loin d'être
facilité par cet adverbe les
temporalités ont changé aujourd'hui à
l'affrontement à partir du moment où il
en est il est connu en temps réel qui
l'information circulait à l'économie en
temps réel les mobilisations se font en
temps réel également
et du coup la sagesse beaucoup moins de
temps pour les coller pour les adultes
pour les acteurs de prévention cela
reste beaucoup moins de temps pour
étouffer étouffer le conflit et d'agir
sur le motif reste que si les réseaux
sociaux peuvent être à l'origine de
certaines échauffourées conduisant à des
affrontements parfois mortelles ils
peuvent aussi avoir un tout autre rôle
celui de lanceurs d'alert c'est le cas
entre autres du lynchage du jeune youri
pour les images de la violente agression
ont été largement relayées sur les
réseaux sociaux
la diffusion de cette vidéo a forcé les
autorités à s'emparer la faire et a
probablement permis une accélération de
l'antenne
[Musique]